it became apparent rather quickly that
that it was a bigger deal than maybe I
thought because it I was mostly just
annoyed that that I had to deal with it
at all let's go back to the beginning
the thing that sort of made you a
national figure although you were a
congressman already let's talk about
Saturday Night Live I'm sure you've
never talked about that before right you
maybe maybe once maybe twice can you
just talk a little bit about that night
you see you see the Pete Davidson sketch
and then just sort of all the fallout
and then what you did ultimately was it
literally I think the next week when you
when you went on the show and just talk
about how that then sort of set you up
to be a more national figure instead of
just you know a congressman from from
Texas yeah
well obviously I wasn't I wasn't really
watching it that night of course you
know nobody is I think most people
digest the most people digest Saturday
Night Live from like the next day's
YouTube videos or something if it's a
good skit and that's that was no
different on this one of course story
started getting written about it I had
not seen it I had some funny text
messages from my buddies that were just
giving me a hard time for it you know we
have a very dark sense of humor and the
teams and it became apparent rather
quickly that that it was a bigger deal
than maybe I thought because it I was
mostly just annoyed that that I had to
deal with it at all
there was a was there was a lot going on
that day it was the Sunday before the
election you know we were doing pretty
well but it but a lot of events I'd to
get to and it felt more like an
annoyance I was not I was not used to
having to respond publicly to things
probably the way I'm more used to that
now yeah you would give twenty people
the one sentence recap of what the skit
was or what the line was there sure so
yeah Pete Davidson was basically going
down a list of quote-unquote gross
people all politicians all all except
for one were Republican and he basically
just makes fun of everybody but with me
he you know at first he's like this guy
he looks kinda like a hitman in a porno
now
pretty funny to be honest but sorry like
you know he lost his eye or whatever
right and it was that it was that single
line that that seems so dismissive of a
war injury that just injure people nuts
and and understandably so and now the
way I analyzed this and the way I
analyzed it in my book is is it was
pretty obvious that he was trying to
take a dig at conservatives right it is
it's the Davidson it's Saturday Night
Live it they dig it Democrats plenty too
but but on this particular skit it was a
very clear swipe at conservatives
because the it's obvious just just watch
it it was not it was obvious that that
he was trying to insult wounded veterans
you know and so there was there was the
thought process the next day was okay
how much grace can we give here while
still while still acknowledging that
many veterans are hurt by this like
genuinely they're pissed off and maybe
they have good reason to be but also I
don't want to unleash this outrage mob
because one I don't feel it you know I
just I genuinely don't feel like this
sense of being offended and it's just
not who I am and so I don't know express
something that I'm not really feeling
either which seems to be the norm and
the surprising thing about all this was
that it was so surprising to people
that'd that I wouldn't unleash the
outrage mob and I said something no my
main quote from that was you know a
quote that I actually stole from a
Harvard professor which was try hard not
to offend people try even harder not to
be offended you know the joke wasn't
very funny but like I'm not gonna call
for this guy to get fired I'm not gonna
like I'm you know
demand that everybody cancels Saturday
Night Live it's just it seems it's just
that felt wrong and so we didn't do it
and that gave Saturday Night Live the
space to actually apologize the way they
wanted to and have me on and I talk
about this in my tribal chapter about
the right sense of shame mm-hmm and this
is the only time I bring up the Saturday
Night Live thing in the book that the
book kind of came about because of the
fame that I got from Saturn
but the book isn't really about that
it's just it just so happens that I I
was directly involved in sort of an
outraged culture moment and so I decided
to write a whole book about the
solutions to outraged culture and but
that moment it takes up like three pages
of the book not even but what I point
out is that there's a right way to show
shame in our culture and there's a wrong
way and more and more and more our
culture is going the wrong way
where we have like these two extreme
options on the one hand people will bow
down to the outraged mom I'm so sorry I
can't believe I did that and I bring up
some examples in the book on that one
one because this one just drove me nuts
was Mario Lopez when he makes the all
too understandable comment that
three-year-olds should not choose their
gender I mean oh my god can't even be
even believe he said that right and then
but what does he do he doesn't say hey
hold on what's wrong with that you know
come on guys he says oh my god I'm so
sorry
I'm so so sorry please please forgive me
right that's the wrong sense of shame
and there's on the other extreme there's
another wrong sense of shame which is
showing no shame at all
mmm-hmm and there's plenty of examples
like that mostly in the political world
but other but in other places as well
and other public figures and and then I
diagnosed like the why is that why is
there this incentive for one or the
other and it's and it's in all of us
problem it's not just our terrible
politicians or silly celebrities it's in
all of us problem we all engage in this
shaming in the wrong way we either we we
overreact to such an extent that we
force people to bow down when they
shouldn't or we overreact to such an
extent that public figures realize
there's no incentive to apologize
because there's no forgiving there's no
huge no redemption there's no forgetting
like and so we have to get back to this
sort of middle ground and people and
there's good examples that I bring up in
the book of that good middle ground too
and we don't we just have to do more of
that be more nuanced than our thinking
nuances like a huge part of solving this
problem
yeah so you you go back on SNL and
there's humor and there's nuance and
decency and all of those things and that
kind of propels you and one of the
things things that I think is sort of
interesting about you is it's like we've
sort of got these cartoon characters on
the left with the squad like äôt and
Alan Omar and to leave and a couple of
others and then there's sort of you on
the other side of that and when you when
you take you and and the eyepatch
they're sort of like you're kind of like
Nick Fury like if we're looking at this
through a marbled lens it's like we
should as we should right I mean but I
mean we're sort of like there's like all
the politicians now it's soil and Trump
and everybody it's sort of like
characters in a movie or in a video game
or something like that but I mentioned
this because it's like it seems like
there's this young crew from the lefties
and then there's sort of you on the
other side of that are there some other
guys that you got guys girls whatever
that that you think are in your crew
that are sort of a younger more get it
more willing to open up talk about these
things I mean you know I've done events
with you where like you know you can be
out there with the students and and it's
not this stuffy thing but it seems like
it's kind of just you holding that for
the for the sort of new more may be
open-minded conservative something like
that yeah that's a good question I do
get asked that a lot and it's a
difficult question because like I don't
want to try and analyze the minds of my
colleagues who who maybe don't put
themselves out there as much I think
maybe a lot would be willing to but they
don't have the same ability to or
they're not sure how there's some really
great members of Congress who are our
age you know like Mike Gallagher Elise
Stefanik and they're out there but you
know they they have their own style
they're not on social media the way I am
they're not out there the way I am
everybody does have their own style I'm
excited about sort of a new squad coming
out of Texas we've got a lot of great
new candidates running very diverse set
very young I'm really excited about it
you know I've got Wesley hunt here next
to me African American army helicopter
pilot got Tony Gonzales running for will
heard see old Master Chief not not old
sorry but prior Master Chief
you know Beth Van Dyne she's a prior
mayor again young like got a lot of very
intelligent got a lot of spunk
Genevieve Collins another great one
again young woman millennial like me you
know very successful got a great shot at
that see if there's there's a lot of
really good candidates and I I think the
Republican Party does have a chance to
like really remake itself in a really
big way that that connects with a lot of
different people so I'm I'm excited
about it yeah is the biggest challenge
they're just getting over sort of the
old stereotypes I mean just the old
stereotypes conservatives care about
money and care about war and you know
Democrats like poor people and peace
like these basic sort of very factory
setting things when it when in reality I
mean we spoke at the turning-point
student action summit and and Trump
spoke that morning and it was right
after the the impeachment hearing and
you wanted to get up in the middle of
his speech you were trying to show him
your vote that you voted against it and
it was like it was a totally impromptu
moment Trump looks at you in the crowd
he's like damn come on up here the
secret the Secret Service guys were all
looking like oh god now we have to get
this guy from the crowd even though he's
a congressman get him on stage but but
he my my broader point is that it was
like fun and real which is so the
reverse of what politics is presented to
us as yeah oh yeah I mean it's totally
changed in the last few years and I
think it's exciting now we have to be
responsible with with how we manage this
new train that's just like lurching
forward right because it is this sort of
interesting combination of like
showmanship with with some deep thinking
and some some real actual statesmanship
it is up to us as leaders to make sure
that we that we maintain those bonds and
and then that balance in a very coherent
way if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlists all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell